I am in the presence of greatness Viola
Davis backstage here presented by City
National Bank whoo are now officially an
e-got winner Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony oh
how does that feel it looks like your
eyes have a little water in them I'm
emotional for you
I'm really emotional my life is really
come full circle I mean I wrote this
book because I was trying to reconcile
my life I was trying to honor the young
Biola you know I was I wanted her to be
excited at the 57 year old she gets to
become and um and this this is just the
icing on the cake what would the young
Viola say knowing that one day she would
hear the words and the Grammy goes to
Viola Davis
she would have been very proud and would
been very proud to run her leg of the
race and she did she was a Survivor and
she brought me to this this place so I
today I honor her with every fiber of my
being now how are you going to celebrate
this very well deserved win I feel like
now that it's you know under your belt
you get to like kind of the pressure's
off today isn't it I may have some
french fries and some sparkling wine
okay now I'm a simple woman
I'm a simple one french fries and
sparkling wine a woman after my own
heart it is so well deserved are you
gonna watch The Telecast tonight too
absolutely I'm going to be back I'm I'm
going to be here
now who are we who are we rooting for
Beyonce Beyonce I mean I I just can't
help it I'm a fan I'm a fan you'll have
that sparkling wine held up high every
time her name's called tonight
absolutely Biola Davis congratulations
I'm so happy for you and uh where's the
trophy gonna go with the with the rest
of them the egot collection yes I'm
gonna put it in the office
congratulations so lovely to chat with
you
[Music]